ouais
[Musique]
c'est le procès du siècle diront
certains un procès sous haute
surveillance est très médiatisée ya la
guerre en ukraine le droit à
l'avortement remis en question mais rien
à faire ce qui fascine les américains si
ce procès en diffamation que mène johnny
depp contre son ex-femme un buffer
chaque jour depuis le 11 avril ses fans
sont nombreux devant le tribunal iphone
à la main pour immortaliser ce moment
johnny depp qui des cellules avec le
sourire
est
resté coupé parce qu'au sénégal
mais à l'intérieur de la cour il n'y a
rien de joyeux
un bug l'accusent de violence physique
psychologique verbale surtout déclenché
lors de forte consommation d'alcool et
de drogues
depuis un mois leur vie privée devenue
publique tout est relatée dans les
moindres détails et diffusé en direct à
la télévision avec vidéo et audio à la
depuis le public se délecte
[Musique]
tout leur linge sale est exposé devant
le monde entier dit cette avocate qui
couvrent le procès depuis le début
il s'agit de diffamation dit-elle
de tripoli et tout repose sur qui des
sept jurés vont croire
que je ne l'aiment pas c'est une
menteuse dit elle
elle pleure mais elle n'a pas de larmes
dit la pancarte
nous n'étions pas là dit il on n'est pas
en mesure de juger comme société il y un
système pour cela
les chèques évoqué son point de vue
enppi pour
les personnes qui prétendent être
victime de violences conjugales sont
extrêmement dangereuses dit elle pour
les vraies victimes de
son histoire ne tient pas dit elle un
burn n'a pas toujours porté plainte et
elle refuse des soins médicaux alors
qu'elle aurait subi de graves déçu et
c'est ce que johnny depp essaie de
prouver qu'un brunch n'a pas dit la
vérité
selon l'acteur a n'a fait que ternir sa
réputation et lui a fait perdre
plusieurs contrats importants dont celui
du film pirates des caraïbes
quelle que soit l'issue du procès dit il
je vais vivre avec ça pour le reste de
mes jours il nie avoir levé la main sur
elle et réclame 50 millions de dollars
en dommages et intérêts we have seen as
d'amitié mouvement comme très en forme
le pendule du mouvement mitu ne balancez
que d'un côté dit cette avocate beaucoup
d'hommes ont été accusés de violences
conjugales et certains étaient prêts
dans ce mouvement et n'ont pas eu la
possibilité de se défendre en cour
johnny depp a décidé de riposter dit
elle en se présentant aussi que l'on
victimes
et syngenta avec cette poursuite jaune
immeuble aura-t-il semer le doute dans
les esprits pour beaucoup il a déjà
remporté la bataille populaire
le contre-interrogatoire d'amber heard
débute le 16 mai prochain il faisait
beau de l'eger glissera du canada
fairfax virginie